d'accueillir notre invité justement pour
nous parler de cette situation en
ukraine et des ukrainiens bonjour adrien
mongeon
vous êtes chercheur à l'inalco vous êtes
spécialiste de l'ukraine vous l'avez
entendu première question avec vous sur
notre plateau on évoquait cet esprit de
résistance de l'ukraine est ce que vous
qui connaissez bien l'ukraine c'est une
surprise pour vous cette attitude des
ukrainiens à défendre leur pays
[Musique]
l'édification
auparavant
on avait en fait une identité multi
positionnelle en ukraine chacun peut
revendiquer voilà plutôt d'une une
communauté de petits de marioupol deux
vip et j'en passe et en fait avec la
révolution puis la guerre dans le bon
bah c'est la nation ukrainienne a pris
conscience de son identité
confidences des longs dans l'ue par l a
retrouvé cette embolie nationaux et il
ya eu en fait à une grotte elle a
retrouvé en fait cette dynamique
nationale à travers différentes
l'initiative que de la sphère politique
mais d'autres villes avec par exemple le
phénomène des bataillons de volontaires
une question avec vous également adrien
mongeon sur le profil du président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky qui a qui a
surpris beaucoup de monde ici ici en
europe mais pas mais pâques en europe
sur qui s'est révélé d'une certaine
manière comme comme chef de guerre à
l'occasion de cette invasion russe alors
qu'il est il un profil particulier c'est
un ancien acteur que dire de lui et que
dire de son de son accueil par la
population ukrainienne
d'abord tout d'abord oui
population à lui même à revêtir
avec le gouvernement
[Musique]
est un acteur
la communication c'est aussi ce rôle
[Musique]
d'avoir un président qui assume enfin
son rôle mais néanmoins il ya quand même
des critiques à l'idée qu'il faut
toujours manipulés par les oligarques et
que se ferait en fait les oligarques et
qui demande à vau l'eau de baignade et
d'agir en tant que tel mais ça
représente une minorité au sein de la
population ukrainienne et à l'otan
départ mais adrien donjon notre
chroniqueur international gauthier
rybinski à une question pour vous
gauchistes avoue oui bonjour adrien dont
je voulais revenir sur un point qui a
été qui est toujours important puisque
vladimir poutine font de son
intervention sur la présence supposée
donner aux nazis au sein du gouvernement
ukrainien est ce que il pense
raisonnablement à ce qu'a pu être le
mouvement nationaliste ukrainien dans
les années 40 qui a prêté main forte au
nazisme est-ce qu'il pense à maidan
oublierait ce qu il se persuade de lui
même de la réalité de ce phénomène et
vous est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
quelle est la réalité de l'extrême
droite ukrainienne aujourd'hui
le narratif et la mythologie qui l'a
compris dès le début de son mandat c'est
narratif propose lui de la seconde
guerre mondiale appelée grande guerre
patriotique sûrs en urss qui à partir de
ce moment-là imagine que chaque invasion
en provenance l'ouest de l'europe voilà
densifier comme fasciste donc forcément
l'avenir je veux fuir les mots sa chance
voilà l'ukraine de par son histoire a eu
des épisodes où voilà elles étaient
obligés de collaborer
circonstanciellement avec les forces
nazies pour gagner son indépendance
s'ajoute à cela également on l'avait
observé des gens en 2004 avec la
révolution orange mais voilà c'est une
révolution
préparé par les américains et à laquelle
en fait l'extrême droite avait participé
d'autant plus que le président qui avait
aidé à remporter les élections des
prochaines qu avait engagé une politique
mémorielle basé sur rebond de différents
symboles mettant en valeur différentes
figures du mouvement nationaliste
ukrainien et bien entendu le maidan où
finalement les phrases mais comme
d'autres mouvements que fois de gauche
ou jeu démocratique ont participé à la
révolution et puis ensuite il ya eu le
phénomène des bataillons de volontaires
aujourd'hui l'extrême droite ukrainienne
et ce depuis en fête le vin et le maïdan
je dirais ne représente aucun poids
politique
il ya eu des tentatives de la part du
parti de se présenter durant les
élections en fin de l'émission mais
jamais au grand jamais à l'extrême
droite on a gagné une telle élection
l'extrême droite est présente certes
dans le vent dans la rue les airs sur un
foie parfois sur la population mais ne
représente pas une menace donc l'idée
derrière le terme dénazification
oberthur cas relève de la faute n'est
plus généralement il pouvoir en fait une
rhétorique ou vladimir poutine dit je
veux simplement sauver l ukraine de
l'occident qui est décadent et le
néonazisme en fait partie mais en tout
cas les freins droite est traitable est
quasiment inexistante sur le plan aérien
dans une question est également
également également avec vous sur les
les peuples étaient ceux qu'on qualifie
d des territoires séparatistes de l'est
de l'ukraine on les présente comme des
russes au film au moins d'aidés des rues
sur saône quelle va être leur attitude
dansez dansez de guerre quelle quelle
position peuvent-ils prendre selon vous
difficile à dire
vernelli soit sur place pour couvrir le
conflit bon la majorité de la population
bien entendu déjà a peur de la guerre
des conséquences vous répond déjà parti
vers la russie qu on ne la fait pas noté
qui sont restés sur place il ya encore
avec avec l'armée russe vladimir poutine
et espère que tôt ou tard l'armée russe
rendre active et des caciques rate il
veut dire le pouvoir en arrêtant et les
gens volent des merengue et l'ensemble
de ses collaborateurs
c'est ça selon vous le but de de l'armée
russe on imagine c'est de mettre une
sorte de gouvernement fantoche en place
en place en ukraine c'est ça
on peut là encore les représentations
historiques de vladimir joue beaucoup en
fait cette idée de vouloir avancer
maintenant coûte que coûte le plus
possible dans la paire la capitale un
prêt en deux temps dans cette mythologie
en fait de la seconde guerre mondiale où
on avait vu les soviétiques pendant leur
high tide par exemple même pendant la
guerre d'afghanistan vous allez le
palais présidentiel donc je pense que
vladimir poutine est en quête de
symboles historiques ont marqué en fait
la présidence est ton rôle de chef de
guerre du côté du côté ruth et donc oui
il ya cette volonté d'arriver le plus
possible et de traduire en justice
volodymyr bénéficient ou pire encore le
mettre hors d'état de nuire merci
beaucoup adrien donjon d'avoir répondu à
nos questions sur france 24 ce samedi je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur à
inalco et spécialiste de l'ukraine
encore merci donc à vous